what up space fam golden here from anime
up we're back at it again with another
one piece video just as i did a similar
video for shanks i thought it was about
time to do one for his swordsmanship
rival mihawk especially considering the
crazy new developments about his
character his true strength his bounty
and more crazy stuff in this video so
make sure to stay tuned for that chill
on the pirate king with it and smash
that like button if you enjoy seeing
these one-piece videos on the channel
and want to keep them coming and if you
do smash it legend has it that youtube
will reward you with on-screen fireworks
straight from wano give it a shot make
this the video subscribe if you haven't
already and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one-piece videos and updates
now i want to thank warframe for
sponsoring this video warframe just
released its 50th warframe called
stionax a mythical javelin and shield
wielding warrior and all players can get
him for free for a limited time only
warframe is a cooperative free to play
third person online action game with
more than 70 million players on pc xbox
series x ps5 nintendo switch and more i
was blown away by the detailed and
smooth graphics in warframe as i quickly
made my way through stages completing
missions defeating enemies with
different weapons of choice from swords
to throwing knives to machine guns and
more this game is amazingly customizable
as you can complete missions any way you
like whether it's by sneaking past some
opponents or whether it's by just taking
down every single one you see with your
chosen warframe and favorite weapon if
you love shonen battle anime and
watching zoro and mihawk slash through
opponents then chances are you'll love
this game where you're the protagonist
styanax will only be available for free
for a limited time so use my link now to
download warframe log in to claim
styanax before this offer expires on
september 21st and you can even watch
the statenx anime short created by
passion paris who also worked on hit
animation projects like love death and
robots so what are you waiting for
become a space ninja like me and enjoy
the fast paced and smooth gameplay of
warframe while unlocking the awesome
styanax all you gotta do is click the
link in the description to download
warframe today and now without further
ado let's jump into its spoilers and all
the 43 year old dracul hawkeyes mihawk
holds the title of the strongest
swordsman in the world in the past he
was known as the marine hunter which is
hype and leads me to believe that that's
why they wanted him to become a warlord
he was known to be yonko shanks's rival
the living yonko with the highest
current bounty at over 4 billion berries
he went on to create the organization
cross guild with crocodile although
mihawk and crocodile are the true
leaders buggy serves as the figurehead
for the organization and we'll get into
more of that later and despite this
despite the fact that he's not the
leader as far as anyone knows our boy
mihawk has a shockingly large bounty of
3.59 billion very close to shanks's and
larger than buggies despite the fact
that he's not even a yonko or the leader
as far as anyone knows of that
organization i mean when it was revealed
the dude had a bounty higher than the
three other yonko aside from shanks it's
crazy so let's look back and see how we
got to this point and how strong mihawk
truly is 41 year old mihawk debuted way
back during chapter 49 that's over 1 000
chapters ago at this point during
chapter 50 we see that don krieg the big
bad guy of the ark is scared of mihawk
who is introduced as the greatest
swordsman in the world we also see that
zoro wants to take him on for the first
time he wants to beat him and become the
greatest swordsman himself but as we
know now he wasn't even close to being
ready and that's an understatement even
mihawk's vessel which is pretty much a
glorified chair lets you know how strong
he must be most people have crews and
still get wrecked like krieg and his men
did in the grand line and this dude is
confident enough to just travel by
himself through the sea and grand line
and like i said what is pretty much a
glorified floating chair zeph who knows
of the master swordsman isn't even
surprised by the fact that he wrecked a
huge galleon with a sword when asked why
he was picking on creek's crew he
replies for fun he effortlessly deflects
bullets with a sword it's clear that as
zoro points out shooting at him is
useless zorro comments that he's never
seen such subtle sword work to which
mihawk replies without subtlety a sword
is but an iron bar i also love when zoro
asks him if he did split the galleon
with a sword and mihawk replies of
course like it's the easiest thing in
the world zoro asks to fight him but
mihawk calls him pathetic in a weakling
he says that if zoro was a competent
swordsman he wouldn't need to cross
swords to know that mihawk far surpasses
his puny skills he wonders if zoro is
confident or just ignorant anzor replies
his courage comes from ambition and from
a promise to a friend mihawk decides to
use a small blade around his neck to
deal with zorro who already has his own
reputation at this point as the infamous
pirate hunter zorro as mihawk says he's
not the kind of fool who hunts rabbits
with a cannon yeah he straight up calls
zoro a harmless bunny compared to
himself he even apologizes for not
having a smaller knife as if zorro
doesn't even deserve the small blade
mihawk to use his own words shows zorro
and us just how big the world is yeah
zoro was a big shot in east blue but
mihawk stops his three blades with his
small one everyone is shocked especially
zoro who comments on how they can't be
this unequal the gap can't be this big
mihawk is clearly having no problem with
zorro despite using a toothpick of a
blade and even puts down zorro for his
heavy-handed swordplay nevertheless the
seemingly constantly bored mihawk is
intrigued by zoro's effort and asks what
drives you why do you fight so hard when
you cannot win you're a weakling and of
course this sounds offensive but from
his expression it looks like mihawk is
actually curious and not trying to
insult zorro finally mihawk decides to
quit towing around and stab zorro he
asks zorro why doesn't he retreat and
zorro responds i can't if i retreat even
one step my vow my ambition everything i
care about will be shattered and all my
dreams will be lost forever end quote
zoro explains that he prefers death to
defeat and mihawk notes zoro's
impressive strength of spirit how he'd
rather die than give up he even asks for
zorro's name zoro gives it mihawk
compliments zorro's spirit by saying
he'll remember his name he adds it's
been a while since he's met someone so
brave he decides to honor the
swordsman's code and pulls out his real
sword he says he'll send zorro to his
death with this black blade the finest
in the world zoro decides this is it his
last chance greatest in the world or
death he prepares to use a move and
mihawk actually sweats it's possible
that he got a glimpse of zoro's conker's
hockey here but it's more so a sign of
potential than anything to worry about
in this fight and mihawk predictably
wins two of zoro's swords break he
accepts that he's outmatched and offers
himself to be taken down by mihawk
saying wounds on the back are a
swordsman's shame the usually stoic
mihawk smiles widely at this and says
magnificent before cutting down zorro
with his blade it may look bad but
mihawk actually held back as he thinks
don't be in a hurry to die young warrior
when a worried luffy shows up mihawk
compliments him saying he did well to
let zorro fight his own battle to the
end he then adds don't worry i left him
alive he tells zoro to discover himself
to see the world and to grow strong he
says that however long it may take he
will await zoro at the top he tells him
to strive with your whole heart and mind
to best this blade fierce one strive to
surpass me rora noah zorro end quote
zeph is wondering why mihawk would say
something like that suggesting it's out
of character and by extension it hypes
up zorro and the potential mihawk sees
in zorro even more zoro vows to luffy
that he will never lose again from now
to the day he beats mihawk to become the
greatest swordsman and mihawk smiles
upon hearing this he hopes to encounter
luffy and zoro again someday he also
decides he doesn't care about krieg's
head anymore saying he's had enough fun
for now so he shall take a nap krieg
tries to attack him again but mihawk is
unaffected and even calls krieg a slow
learner mihawk was so impressive that
krieg couldn't help but think that
mihawk broke the ship by using some
devil fruit power we eventually find out
that he was famous even before the great
pirate age that began 24 years ago in
fact he was present at gold d rogers
execution the marine hunter title
probably came from the fact that he
defeated many marines in his earlier
years he challenged strong swordsman
after strong swordsman until there was
no one left to challenge his title of
greatest swordsman he saw a worthy rival
in shanks and dueled him multiple times
even whitebeard couldn't help but
remember one of their legendary battles
saying and i quote there aren't many who
speak of the legend anymore your duel
with hawkeye is still fresh in my memory
end quote sometime after roger's death
mihawk joined the warlord system and
like i said my assumption would be that
the marines wanted to deal with the
marine hunter and killing him was
probably unrealistic or would take way
more manpower than they could spare so
they made it well worth his while to
become a warlord it should be noted that
he was offered this position as an
individual without a crew or underlings
which is very unique and speaks to his
insane power as an individual he also
stopped dueling shanks eventually after
shanks lost his arm protecting luffy we
learned this during chapter 96 when he
goes to visit shanks on a certain island
as some of the pirates get spooked by
mihawk he tells them not to get excited
he's here for their captain shanks he
also comments to himself that camping on
this island is careless of shanks when
they meet shank says that hawkeye
showing up is unexpected and that he's
in a bad mood he wonders if he's here to
challenge him but mihawk replies that he
doesn't challenge one armed husbands
talking like this to yonko shanks is in
itself noteworthy and of course the
implication is that mihawk doesn't
challenge him anymore because it's
beneath him he's not the worthy rival he
was before this exchange has been a
point of contention for many one piece
fans obviously shanks is strong and we
know he should have gotten stronger
since losing his arm and becoming a
yonko but mihawk is putting himself
above shanks saying he's no longer even
worth challenging the question is how
much is this mihawk's true feelings and
how much is it some friendly teasing
between friends we do get more info in
the latest chapters that will shed more
light on this so we will get back to it
later mihawk actually came this time
because he found an interesting pirate
namely luffy that shanks had told him
about shang smiles upon learning that
luffy has joined the pirate world and
invites mihawk to drink with him this
friendly dynamic seems to characterize
shanks and mihawk's relationship these
days since shanks lost his arm and
stopped being viewed by mihawk as a
rival later during chapter 234 mihawk
joins a meeting about crocodile between
the two great powers of the seven
warlords and the high command of the
navy people didn't even expect to see
him there suggesting he had special
privileges even among the warlords but
he says he's just here as an interested
bystander he's a little curious about
the pirates they'll be discussing and of
course the discussion is about crocodile
and who will replace him which ends up
being blackbeard here one of the pirates
that mihawk may have been curious about
was crocodile and in the first chapters
mihawk appeared buggy was in the cover
art so it's interesting how the cross
guild organization was foreshadowed so
early on when you really think about it
then we jump to the marineford arc where
warlord mihawk answered the navy's call
to aid in the war against the whitebeard
pirates of course as usual he had his
own reasons for joining the war when
whitebeard shows up and mihawk pulls out
his sword doflamingo asks are you really
going to fight to which mihawk responds
i just want to measure the true distance
between that man and us and keep in mind
whitebeard was called the strongest man
in the world and the one closest to one
piece although this is an older sicker
and weaker version of him compared to
his prime mihawk launches an attack with
the swing of his sword from a very long
distance at whitebeard diamond josue is
the one to stop it from reaching
whitebeard but it's noteworthy that
mihawk slash was still called the
strongest in the world aka the world's
most powerful sword slash i mean that is
a hype statement right there and you
know shanks has definitely released some
sword slashes but more on that later
despite the hype statements mihawk
didn't really wow us as much as we might
have expected from a rival of shanks
during the war the fact that one of
whitebeard's commanders deflected
mihawk's attack without whitebeard
needing to do anything was a bit
anti-hype even if we should keep in mind
that jozu has a naturally effective
devil fruit against slashes and that
mihawk did attack from a very long
distance away and without breaking a
sweat he definitely didn't look like
someone giving it his all but more like
someone testing the waters later when
mihawk discovers that luffy is dragon's
son he is not shocked even saying that
nothing would surprise him at this point
about luffy before attacking luffy says
to himself sorry red haired but this
power knows no restraint he's clearly
close enough to shanks to apologize to
him for attacking one of his friends
mihawk says now fate how will you deal
with this heaven-sent boy will his life
end or will he escape this black blade
it's almost like he's challenging the
universe to save luffy because he's so
sure he'll end him right now it's funny
chapter 561 is called luffy vs mihawk
but it's such a click bait title we know
luffy is not strong enough to take on
mihawk at this point and he even says
himself he doesn't have time to fight
someone that strong since he has to save
ace despite his attempt to avoid him
mihawk's hawkeyes lock in on him from a
distance and he launches an attack that
cuts luffy and clearly hurts him he
notes matter-of-factly to luffy that
he's not out of his range yet mihawk
closes the distance in no time and now
luffy is in big trouble mihawk one shots
two newcomer sword wielders effortlessly
luffy prepares to attack and then stops
sensing that if he launched the attack
his hands would have been cut off mihawk
even compliments him saying he's much
calmer than expected luffy is not in a
situation right now where he can just
throw all he's got at the enemy that
worked on early antagonists but he has
to be more strategic and careful here
and to his credit he is he runs and
dodges rather than thinking he can
overpower mihawk in one instance he
dodges an attack that ends up slicing
clean through a giant iceberg and it
subsequently falls not gonna lie that
was very impressive and cool to see and
just a side note that will be relevant
when we get the cross guild during all
this mayhem doflamingo asks crocodile to
team up and crocodile despite being an
earlier antagonist says don't pretend
we're equals maybe you want to be my
henchman pretty big flex indeed and one
worthy of a character who would later on
rise to extreme relevancy once again but
for now we're following mihawk and luffy
although mihawk isn't breaking a sweat
he does repeatedly attack luffy and
every time luffy succeeds in dodging him
however as mihawk points out while
dodging luffy is only getting further
and further from ace aka he's being
pushed back by the attacks luffy then
tries to use buggy as a shield and
distraction as we know buggy doesn't get
cut so mihawk's attacks have no effect
against him either buggy blasts mihawk
with a muggy ball but mihawk just
deflects it back into buggy's face some
youtube comments even joked when
crossguild was first brought up that
mihawk submitted to buggy because he was
powerless to cut him in this exchange
even though mihawk obviously still got
the better of the exchange and buggy was
hit by his own explosive then after
marco tells him to mihawk gets
intercepted by vista the flower blade
leader of the 5th division of the
whitebeard pirates mihawk pays him a big
compliment and lets us know he's a big
deal when he says only an ignoramus
wouldn't know avista then mihawk drops
the famous quote about luffy saying it's
not his powers or techniques he
possesses some quality that makes people
want to help him and in these waters
that is the most formidable power of all
vista succeeds in holding off mihawk and
luffy escapes so again compared to what
shanks is about to do mihawk doesn't
seem that impressive here but it should
be noted that battles do last long in
one piece like how yamato could hold off
kaido for a while and just because they
last longer doesn't mean that the two
fighters are that close in strength in
other words i don't think we should
assume that vista and mihawk are similar
levels just because the former succeeds
in holding him off for a while
eventually mihawk says they should
settle this later and vista agrees
saying it seems that would benefit both
of them later when luffy and ivankov try
to reach ace mihawk again goes after
luffy das bones blocks the attack under
crocodile's orders however to mihawk's
credit he does cut down daw's bones
immediately then crocodile intercepts
his future business partner and that
again gives luffy a chance to escape
notably there does seem to be respect
between these two since mihawk as with
vista uses crocodile's name so it's
clear that luffy could only escape
mihawk because of all the people that
interfered even though we wouldn't
consider these characters anywhere near
shanks's level they do succeed in
holding mihawk back from luffy and again
to hype up crocodile he tells mihawk
he's not in a good mood right now so
hawkeye had better watch out first his
comments are doflamingo and now this
crocodile is definitely talking big and
some people mentioned that crocodile
doesn't have haki because it hasn't been
focused on even armament haki since we
didn't see him use it per se but that's
hard to believe although haki hadn't
really been developed in the story at
this point in order to counter mihawk's
black blade i feel like crocodile would
have had to had at least armament haki
but to be fair it hasn't been confirmed
i just feel like someone as strong as
crocodile has to have it then of course
we have the famous moment where shanks
and his crew stop the war and mihawk's
response to shanks's arrival was that he
never agreed to fight shanks and he
stopped fighting right there on the spot
now to be fair mihawk wasn't sweating or
beaten up or anything at this point so
it's easy to say he didn't give it his
all or had more to give etc but one
can't deny that when shanks showed up no
one would accept his challenge and
multiple sub yonko characters like vista
and crocodile did succeed in holding
mihawk back and he couldn't easily deal
with them so at this point shanks seems
a lot stronger even if it should be
noted that the reaction shanks got
should not only be attributed to the
threat he posed but also the threat of
his entire crew has to be taken into
account when looking at how everyone
responded after the war mihawk went back
to his island and eventually zoro showed
up zoro fought against the human drills
aka baboons or monkeys that imitate
people and zorro had trouble with them
in the beginning but after hearing what
happened to luffy at marine ford he felt
like he had to make it to sea again
mihawk told him the baboons can be a
handful and that zorro can come to
mihawk's castle since the monkeys never
get close another subtle nod to mihawk's
power probably but zoro refuses
eventually when realizing that luffy
wants them to now meet in two years not
three days zoro goes and bows down to
mihawk begging the swordmaster to teach
zoro what he knows mihawk is
disappointed at first that he would beg
his enemy to instruct him he asks him if
he has no pride mihawk tells zoro to
leave at once saying he'll have no
business with a wretch like him he
continues it seems i overestimated you
what are you doing you're only
humiliating yourself and quote zoro
responds he wants to get stronger to
which mihawk says thrashed by the
monkeys and unable to go out to sea i
have nothing to teach a man who can't
finish what he starts end quote then we
get a cool twist where zorro says he
beat the monkeys to mihawk's shock and
that mihawk is the only one left to take
down zorro says he's not stupid enough
to think he can take down mihawk yet he
tells mihawk he wants the strongest
swordsman in the world to instruct him
so that zorro can surpass him one day
and to this again the stoic mihawk
breaks into uncharacteristic laughter he
says you want me to teach you the sword
so that one day you can take my head
you're a strange one you're still a
shameless fool so you value something
more than your own pride and quote and
then he agrees to instruct him once
zoro's wounds heal he also thinks to
himself that zorro is a clumsy fool and
when a man of his caliber abandons his
pride it is always for the sake of
another and in this case we can assume
it's for luffy's sake i love this
exchange because again it shows how
confident mihawk is in his own power he
already let zoro live during the barathe
arc so that he could become stronger and
challenge him again but now he's taking
it further and offering to train a much
stronger zorro who wants to defeat him
it's a huge flex on mihawk's part that
he takes zorro on as a student not even
worried about the fact that zoro wants
to defeat him truly legendary behavior
from mihawk so mihawk went on to train
him for two years and taught zoro how to
imbue his source with haki and although
some people claim that zoro may already
be able to beat mihawk i think that the
conversation shouldn't even be on the
table until zorro succeeds in turning
his swords into permanent black blades
as mihawk did during the whole cake
island arc we learned through a cover
story that mihawk was able to get the
monkeys to not only leave him alone as
we know but also to help him till the
old battleground of the former muggy
kingdom another nod to his strength
since he was able to get those
aggressive and wild human drills to
submit to his authority and so we get to
wano country the ark that went a long
way and re-hyping up mihawk after as i
explained he left something to be
desired at marineford especially when
compared to yonko shanks his long-time
rival slash friend after the world
government disbanded the warlord system
the marines came after mihawk asking him
to surrender initially mihawk said he
felt the thrill of excitement again
since it had been so long since he was
chased however despite being strong
enough to not get caught thrill
eventually turned into annoyance and so
comes in cross guild crocodile calls
miak one day despite clashing at
marineford these two clearly have enough
respect for one another to hear each
other out it's at this point that mihawk
tells crocodile the navy has his island
surrounded at the moment and so he needs
to pick up and move base as bothersome
as it may be it's at this point that
crocodile says that's why he should come
over to crocodile side with their
combined names the navy would have to
sit up and take notice crocodile even
points out that hawkeye was known as the
naval hunter aka marine hunter once
which is such a good detail again
although pirate hunter sounds cool
marine hunter is way cooler you'd have
to be insanely strong to get away with
being a solo marine hunter and beyond
that as mentioned it seems like they
couldn't deal with him and so they
offered him the position of warlord to
get him to stop and ironically mihawk
and crocodile find common ground in the
fact that they both have distrust for
others it's telling that crocodile
wanted mihawk to be his partner even
though they've clashed before we also
find out that mihawk's bounty is a
whopping 3.59 billion which is insane
when you consider he's not even a yonko
in fact even though the government
thinks that he's following buggy they
still gave mihawk the bigger bounty
something we've never seen before as far
as i remember furthermore the marines
didn't just call him the strongest
swordsman in the world they also said
that he has greater sword skill than
even shanks and it is at this point that
once again you can start to make the
argument that mihawk is stronger than
shanks as individuals again it's a gray
area and we don't know a lot of details
for certain and shanks has been hyped up
more than mihawk you can't deny that but
it's completely justifiable now to raise
the possibility that mihawk is stronger
think about it mihawk and shanks dueled
with swords and mihawk got the title of
the strongest swordsman mihawk said he
would no longer fight a one-armed has
been the marines pointed out that he had
greater sword skill than shanks and his
bounty is not far off from shanks's
despite the fact that he's not a yonko
if he were viewed as a yonko at the head
of a formidable crew like shanks it is
easy to imagine mihawk's bounty being
even higher than shanks's and arguments
that shanks didn't use hockey or
something like that in their fights
makes no sense compared to what we've
been taught to expect from the series
characters always use hockey in fights
we never saw mihawk push that hard so
it's completely possible that even he
has very impressive conquerors haki as
well keep in mind as a non yonko mihawk
had a bounty that at the time of the
reveal was as far as we knew higher than
three yonko bounties but with chapter
1059 we find out that blackbeard has
moved ahead to be even closer to shanks
at
3.996 billion still it can't be denied
that mihawk is clearly yonko level and
although i think shanks is viewed as a
bigger threat because he controls his
powerful crew as well i think it's very
possible that mihawk could win in a
one-on-one fight albeit when you compare
mihawk moments like not being able to
get luffy because vista and crocodile
got in the way to shanks moments when he
stopped the war and scared off admiral
greenville with justice hockey i
completely understand why there are
people making the counter argument that
shanks is stronger and there may well be
a loophole for how oda plans to sidestep
the whole mihawk being the strongest
swordsman and shanks being a swordsman
thing however more than ever now the
argument can be made that mihawk could
win although it would obviously be one
of those long epic fights like with
sakazuki and kuzon and keep in mind
mihawk is pretty much a yonko now as we
found out recently buggy is a figurehead
and mihawk and crocodile are pretty much
the ones in charge and even with that
being said it was miha who made the
executive decision to let buggy be the
face of the organization and crocodile
went along with his decision suggesting
that mihawk the one with the highest
bounty is the one calling the shots when
he wants to and that wraps up everything
we know about mihawk up to this point
and shows how there were moments that
made us question if he could really be
as strong as shanks and there were
moments as well that suggested he's
stronger one-on-one at least however
even mihawk acknowledges that one on one
is not the most dangerous power the most
dangerous power is when people want to
help you as he noticed with luffy and
this was reaffirmed when he decided to
join cross guild rather than continuing
on alone allies are powerful and shanks
always had more but mihawk has started
to surround himself with some as well
and again the only way i can explain the
fact that vista and crocodile were able
to hold back a yonko level character is
by pointing to the fact that fights in
one piece are not like fights in other
series even if the gap is big as i
mentioned with kaido and yamato fights
can still take a while so in that case
it's not all that surprising that
someone who could potentially beat
shanks eventually would get held back by
weaker but not weak characters like
vista and crocodile but let me know your
thoughts have an open mind and tell me
your honest thoughts about the famous
mihawk vs shanks debate the point with
this video was not to give a definitive
answer to something oda has tiptoed
around and yet chosen not to reveal but
to retrace mihawk's steps so that we
have a better idea of his power and to
spark discussion i for my part have to
admit that chapter 1058 definitely
influenced the way i personally view the
mihawk vs shanks debate now channel the
pirate king with it and smash that like
button if you enjoyed the video and want
to keep the one piece videos coming
legend has it that youtube will reward
you with on-screen fireworks straight
from wano make this the video you
subscribe if you haven't already and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates while you
wait for the next one-piece video to
drop feel free to check out my large and
growing one-piece playlist that includes
videos on all mythical zone users all
admirals an hour-long video like this
one about shanks and much more link to
that is in the description on screen
right now and until next time see you
space cowboys